president of the united states joe biden
america's commander-in-chief called this
moment the test of all time
ukraine and its western allies taking on
russia's vladimir putin democracies
against autocracies and he didn't hold
back
putin has the gall
to say he did not define ukraine
it's a lie
it's just cynical he knows that
and it's also obscene
he reached out to ordinary russians
let me say this if you're able to listen
you the russian people are not our enemy
i refuse to believe that you welcome the
killing of innocent children and
grandparents
or that you accept hospitals schools
maternity wards for god's sake being
pummeled
with russian missiles and bombs
then a final personal assault on
russia's leader ukraine will never be a
victory for russia
for free people refused to live in a
world of hopelessness and darkness
we will have a different future a
brighter future rooted in democracy and
principle hope and light
of decency and dignity of freedom and
possibilities
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
the white house was quick to clarify joe
biden wasn't calling for regime change
though his feelings about putin had
already been made clear on this trip to
poland
here meeting ukrainian refugees in
warsaw
you're dealing every day with vladimir
putin
and
look at what he's done to these people
what does it make you think he's a
butcher
on the fourth and final day of a trip to
europe president biden also held talks
with the polish leader
it's a sign of the vital role this
country is playing in the west's support
to ukraine's war effort
many weapons gifted by nato allies to
the ukrainian military are sent over the
polish border into its war-torn neighbor
the american president apparently gave
assurances this flow of arms would
continue as he met separately with
ukraine's visiting foreign and defense
ministers
another key topic is bolstering the
alliance's own defenses to deter russian
aggression
unlike ukraine poland is a member of the
nato alliance it means an attack on this
country would be considered an attack
against all requiring a collective
response the u.s is keen to reinforce
this principle of article 5 as allies
adjust to the new security reality
triggered by russia's war next door
and it's still raging with moscow
targeting new ukrainian positions
president biden warned the invasion
threatens to trigger a return to decades
of war that ravaged europe last century
he said that cannot be allowed to happen
poland's tomb of the unknown soldier a
reminder of the continent's deep scars
allies know they must stay united and
become stronger if they're going to meet
the challenge of these changing times
debra haynes sky news warsaw